I won't post selfies online but the
point where I realized I didn't want to
post selfies was just after I ran over
the finish line of a marathon a couple
of years ago and at that point I think I
had maybe 10,000 followers on Twitter
and I took a photo of myself having
crossed the Finish Line looking like
hell I nearly pressed send and then I
was like well don't do that I did not
post the selfie of myself having just
crossed the Finish Line why because I
realized if I did probably 75% of the
people who follow me would say great
well done congratulations and I get lots
of love the other 25% would be the
people who hate follow there would have
been one mean comment which would have
just crushed me and it would have ruined
my day and I thought what's the easiest
way of not experiencing that one mean
comment don't post a picture but it's
more than that it's also that it exposes
something intimate and personal that
moment was for me and it was for my
family and for the people who' supported
me it wasn't for General consumption no
selfies no selfies no pictures of my
home no pictures of my child no pictures
of my husband no discussing my husband
my child or my home except in the most
general terms I have no right to M that
for content